I coming to this video playing Goudy ok
let's transpose into the Smith more this
is a fun transposition ok it declines it
how'd us maybe I can play a delayed with
Maura I know yeah he really doesn't want
the Paul okay so but what happened I we
gotta a French type of position where he
has played though somewhat strange shank
for a 62 before yeah you should dt2 is
probably not bad as well okay he wants
to go Bishop be fine but this is not so
easily possible but should be five now
yeah beehive is just a weakness that
chant get lost here he born to keep the
pawn it's close to impossible
and the dark squares are a terribly weak
okay so how to proceed now as also a
form takes Queen B 7
okay keep it simple develop this with
with sort of a temple threatening to
take and then we'll be one to just try
to to grab the poem maybe we should be
to hospital yeah okay
yeah maybe we should be two was better
because right here but the bush
appointee to i just ate b5 and i'ma
grown up antioch will be five here now
they can yeah he can take c3 this isn't
completely clear cut Cabot not bad
choice
how to do but then i can take b7 hmm
maybe this first
b7 the sun is still hanging
and maybe I should even first take it
seven and then be something
yeah this isn't so easy technically
mostly because my default point is a
weakness yeah Bishop c5 was pretty
really not so great okay just take this
whoop eh i have Bishop e7
yeah this is not easy at all probably
this isn't even good he's got lots of
pressure on da phone just rotated now
yeah do I need to
you have to take you first and this is
such a stupid piece I need to I need to
take it okay Knight to f5 this is the
way to to activate and you're
threatening and not really to take on
edge okay I need to make some to make
some space here anyway
two
take on the seventh book one to be seven
I would be nice the porn is not
important I need to activate pieces
Brooks need to be activated yeah this is
assisting us now be 7 i'm not sure what
he's doing maybe he needs to play rook
somewhere to a 7 okay it took it hmm so
let's see
g 4g for would have been very good ah g4
would have trapped the night ok all
right it's still a threat ok maybe look
III now and then you wants to sack the
sack the exchange but ok this wait wait
wait wait wait wait if i take here and
oh this is even stronger f5f three and
then i take on e6 and he cannot take on
e6 yeah this is stronger it's made g 787
is made you cannot take on e6 now and
I'm threatening e7 and I'm threatening
to take and both us it's very very
strong yeah taking taking us the bigger
threat to a getting into winning king
opponent game and he's no way to prevent
that if i take here than this the porn
coming yep I can't just take a play 687
or Mookie 78 something like that black
resigns yeah yeah I wasn't so sure Roger
thought black would be okay here at the
computer actually agrees
it wants to take a to now until it's
about equal here white has got an edge
according to the comp interesting edgy
for a stronger of course and here he's
got oh here black can get a good
position with look a one check
interesting cat check and drug everyone
I didn't see that okay now it says it's
the draw
hmm now this is cute check check check
this is a draw I'm threatening made and
he needs to he needs to give a perpetual
rook a8 qg three years a double attack
and okay this is chestal a perpetual
along the seven what again what a we get
weird end yeah the interesting game
thanks for watching